well mr president
barack
i have to tell you
every time i hear a dial tone i think of
harry
you all think i'm kidding i'm not
phil and i are here for harry but
he uh
i think he would he wouldn't want us to
really be here for just him
as everybody has referenced
ander we're here for you and for the
family
you love jesus for the living
you know it's a true love story
when you're still talking about your
first date
60 years later gov
harry never tired of telling the time
your two kids had to push start his car
making your way down the
road wide smiles on your face
my recollection is he called it when he
told me the story
one of those quote moments
eternal life
and i stay with you
until the last breath
landra
what a life you turned together
until his last breath
lana and
rory and leif josh key
all the grandchildren
great-grandchildren
seeing and hearing you talk about him
today
it's clear
my dad used to have an expression
and say
you were blood of his blood bone of his
bone
you are the product of harry and
lander reed
what a gift
what a gift god gave you
what a gift
that was and is
elder ballard
president obama vice president harris
second gentleman
governor uh
fishlock
thanks to passport into the state
and uh iris
and
chuck schumer
and
paul and nancy pelosi
members of the nevada congressional
delegation
senator cortez mastiles and rosen and
representatives heart excuse me horsford
and lee and titus
members of congress democrat republican
past and president distinguished guest
what a gift
harry reid was to the state to this
nation
and to so many of us
individually
i know he's smiling right now
only harry reid
at
his
send-off
would
sandwich the speaker between
former president united states carol
king and the killers
thanks harry
you've always had a great sense of humor
he always had to win
and he always did
he got me again
but he always got me the first time
i met harry i got a call asking whether
as i just been elected at 29 years old
in the united states senate i hadn't
even turned 32 yet
he was a newly i was a newly elected
senator he asked me
to campaign for his election for
nevada's senate seat being vacated by a
man i'd only just begun to know alum
bible
the first thing when he met i met him in
nevada
we were talking about where he's from
and he said well
i used to have to go out and shoot mad
dogs
i thought what in the hell am i doing
here
i swear to god i used to go out and
shoot mad dogs i'm thinking bless me
father for i have sinned what's going on
how he lost that general election by
less than 600 votes to paul laxall
and uh he never let me forget thinking
that i probably cost him those 600 votes
i'm only kidding about that piece
but i probably did
but when he asked me to come back and
campaign for him when he ran for the
house in 1982
he won that time
then he won in 86
and we go on to serve in congress
together for more than 30 years
we worked together with barack during
the eight years we were in office and
even when harry was done in the senate
he was never really done
as all of you from nevada know
he'd asked me to campaign for an awful
lot of nevada democrats
many of whom are here today
i could never say no although you
probably said oh god he invited biden
into my district
well i talked to him often during this
past election
taking his advice and laundry can tell
you come into his home and more than one
occasion to visit and get his advice
and where i should be going
in order to win
after he won
one of the things that harry did which
was
sort of incongruous with harry
as you've heard today
he sent me a text
i've saved it
i said i'm so
joe you're my brother
we won
well
made a big deal to me it was a big deal
to me that he felt that way
you know harry never wrote what he
didn't believe
it made me feel good
he gave me
a sense of confidence
i felt like he was my brother
i counted on him
i know so many of you felt that same way
about harry as well throughout his
career and your relationship with them
over five decades we became genuine
friends
the irish catholic kid from scranton
pennsylvania and latter-day saints from
searchlight
you think i'm kidding
but harry is like the guys i grew up
with
back in scranton and claymont delaware
harry would always have your back
like the guys i grew up with
harry had mine
and he knew i had his
although i sometimes wondered
when i was trying to make an important
point to harry about whether he really
did have my back as he hung up
but to tell the truth every time
every time he would do it
i knew it was real the real harry
it was him
he had all he needed he didn't want any
more or need anymore
we did
share some similarities
as barack said we have loving families
wives are smarter and better looking
than we were
and harry and i both like to talk a lot
i'm just testing whether you're asleep
yet
but whether you served with harry for
decades or uh
where you were new to america just a few
days ago
you wanted harry in your corner and
that's not hyperbole
his toughness was distinctly nevada
his story
was unmistakably american
his remarkable journey has been told so
many by so many
because
it has been traveled by so few
desert shacky called home
miles to hitchhike to school boxing ring
where he always got up
family tragedies endured to cancer he
and laundra fought
the halls of power he walked the state
he transformed the country he shaped
he was proof
that there's nothing
ordinary about america
ordinary americans can do anything
given half a chance
we the people
pretty damn extraordinary
america's an idea
an idea
that anybody
giving a shot
can reach their potential harry was
extraordinary though
he and i grew up in different sides of
the country we came from the same place
where certain values ran deep
first loyalty
faith resolve service
your word
just pounded into my head from the time
i was a child
joe you're a man even word without your
word you're not a man
and he met
the marker
what i always believed was the most
important thing which you can measure a
person by
their actions and keeping their word
if harry said he was going to do
something
he did it
he didn't do what the modern day
rationale is when i told you i would do
that i didn't realize that this would
happen
no matter what happened
he gave you his word he kept it
you could bank on it
that's how he got so much done for the
good of the country for so many decades
that's how we literally saved we forget
it social security
during the bush years
stop yucca mountain from becoming a
nuclear waste site
secured the votes of the affordable care
act
it's how he helped us reign in wall
street the excesses and repeal don't ask
don't tell
it's how created nevada's first national
park and can serve lake tahoe
now we always championed
native americans and tribal communities
so much more
none of it was easy
not a lot of was positive particularly
popular when he was doing it
the thing about harry
he never
gave up
he never gave up
he never gave up on anybody
he cared about
like every great leader
he led the democratic caucus just not by
speaking but by listening
by hearing all points of view
finding the common ground
harry cared so much about his fellow
americans
and so little about what anybody thought
of him
it was all searchlight no spotlight
i always appreciate
the private comfort and so does jill's
with me tonight
and he offered me and jill in difficult
moments in our lives
we know we're not the only ones
since his passing
we've all heard those wonderful tributes
the gracious way he was consoled
grieving the grieving and encouraged
someone living with a disability
i still have that picture of our buddy
max baucus
max losing three of his limbs he's
harry's standing in front of the
wheelchair holding his cheeks
you know
max knew
max
knew
how he cared about him
the generous way would empower a new
colleague or insist
that the new moms and dads on his staff
would put their family first
even before their job and do it always
the genuine friendship he made with the
capitol police had been recognized three
times because he was one of them he wore
the uniform
to a friend in need
harry's voice was soft and gentle
in praise of himself
he was stone cold silent
pursuit of fairness and prosperity
his voice would echo when will echo for
generations in this state
look
let there be no doubt
harry reid will be considered one of the
greatest
senate majority leaders in history
i've served longer than all without 12
united states senators
served there for over 36 years i've had
the honor of serving
with a few of those names to be on that
short list
for harry
it wasn't about powers about the sake
of power about the power to be able to
use power
through right by people
that's why he wanted harry in your
corner
and that's what we should remember
as a nation today
harry knew better than most how
difficult democracy is
that the idea of america itself is under
attack
from dark and deepening forces
that we're in a battle for the soul of
america
londo i remember sitting in a room with
harry when he was supporting me for
president
am i explaining to him
the reason i decided to run when i had
decided i was never going to do that
again
i was watching all those
neo-nazis
come out of the fields down in
virginia
chanting anti-semitic bible
carrying nazi flags
and he asked me what i said
we have to restore the soul
of america no one knew it better than
harry
protecting democracy requires
vigilance stewardship
but harry's life shows that for all
from our darkest days
we can find light and find hope
just look at his life
it's just about every respect
harry reid came into this world with the
odds against him
he believed life
and he lived it and he left it
believing anything was possible
he's demonstrated that anything is
possible look at this incredible family
carrying a small way
reminds me of my dad
my dad used to say joey
never explain
and never complain
remember one day we were having an event
when i was running for my
this was
fifth term
we're at my house
i was feeling a little sorry for myself
talking about a family
loss of a daughter
my dad
he said i'll be back in a minute
he left the house we were waiting for
people to show up
went up to the local
hallmark store
and came back
with a cartoon that was a little brass
plaque
with
two
sections to it
there were two clips from the cartoon
character hagar the horrible
and one hagar the viking
on a ship
have been
moving along near the rocks
lightning comes out of the sky charges
the horns of his helmet
breaks the mast of his ship
and he's looking up at god he's going
god why me
in the next frame is a picture with
hagar and the ship and a voice coming
down from heaven saying
why not
that was my dad
what makes you so special these things
wouldn't happen to you
why not
stand up
get up
never bow never bend never yield
that was harry
never
complain that's why i was admired so
much about it
above harry's desk as we all know the
senate office was a giant portrait of
mark twain
they both harry and mark twain love
nevada they both they both both knew how
to say things
we know to be true about ourselves and
about our country
for harry
it was this
as he said himself he said quote
i grew up around people of strong values
even if they rarely talked about them
went on to say they love their country
worship god
never shunned hard work
and never asked for special favors
that's harry
it's america
here's someone
mark twain himself would have written
about
as a defining character in american
story had he known harry
to his staff known as team reed
we lost
an incredibly genuine role model
but we see you carrying on hmr's legacy
the people of nevada you lost a beloved
son
but the spirit's always going to burn as
bright as the desert sun
it's a nation we lost a
giant america
a plain spoken
honorable decent brave
unyielding man
may this be his legacy
call on each of us to be our best
to speak truth in the heart
to take up the remaining rounds of harry
reid's good fight
the america we all love
what a gift
is from the bottom of my heart what a
gift
what a life of a nation
that he turned until those last breath
landra god bless you
god bless the entire family
god bless my friend harry
a great american
may god protect our troops